[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تقع جل البلدان العربيه في المنطقه
الواقعه بين مدار السرطان ومدار الجدي
وهذه البقعه تتعامد عليها الشمس طوال فتره
الصيف فالحراره اصل في اجوائها صيفا
والبروده مستورده من خارجها شتاء عبر
الرياح الشماليه والخريف يولد من رحم
الصيف ولاده طبيعيه والربيع يولد من رحمه
الشتاء ولاده متعسره اي انه موسم التقلبات
الجويه الحاده فرياحه جانبه للغبار
والاتربه وامطاره مشوبه بحبات براد وقصف
رعده وميض برقه مهلكه للحرث والنسل
وبانتهاء موسم الربيع نهجر الاجواء
الجميله واللطيفه بناظرك الفتان امنت
بالسحر وهل بعد ايمان الصبابه من كفر فلا
تعتمد بالهدر قتل متيم فان المنايا لا
عن الهدر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام تدخل علينا مرحله
الامطار الصيفيه وهي امطار تتشكل محليا
وهطولها يكون في بقعه دون ثانيه وتسمى
عندنا عند العامه بامطار المراويه واهل
الخليج يسمونها بالسرايات وعاده ما تكون
مسبوقه بعصف ريح ان الحليمه اذا ثارت
حميته مثل العواصف لا تبقي
ولا تذروا
[موسيقى]